Hello! Using Web Audio with streamed content is really easy. I’m going to show you the most simple
example we can do, directly on JSBin.
I first create an audio element, using the standard way.
Here we are, ok, [music] so this is just the standard audio element. I will add the “crossOrigin=anonymous”
attribute because when we stream audio content and we control it with
Web Audio, we need to follow the “same origin policy” constraint. That means that the
HTML page and the JavaScript code that manipulate the content of the stream, should be normally
located on the same server as the audio file. This is not the case here because the HTML
I’m typing is hosted on jsbin.com. By adding the “crossOrigin=anonymous” attribute, this
will send different HTTP headers to the mainline.i3s.unice.fr server. And this server has been configured
for accepting external requests. So this will make the example work.
From JavaScript, if I want to get the audio stream, I must first wait until the page is loaded.
I’m writing a window.onload event listener, and the first thing I do is to get
a handle on the audio player. I need to add an id attribute here… Ok, like that!
Like the canvas, that is using a graphic context, here, with Web Audio, we use an audio context.
So, I created the context. Now, I can create a special source node using context.createMediaElementSource,
that takes as a single parameter a video or an audio element. I’m using the player variable here,
that corresponds to the audio element.
Now, I connect this source to the destination. A destination is a special node that corresponds
to the speakers. Each node has a connect and a disconnect method. I’m using the connect
method here, and I’m using ctx.destination as the destination node. If I play it [music], the stream
is going directly to the speakers. And if I comment this line, the string is disconnected
and nothing is outputed. Once you got an handle on the audio stream, using createMediaElementSource,
the behavior of the audio element is changed; all the signal, the audio signal, is routed
to your own audio graph, not to the default route that goes to the speakers.
And I can visualize this graph. With JsBin, I need to be in standalone mode, like that.
I open the devtools, I check that Web Audio is activated, here, and now I can go to the
Web Audio tab, reload the page, and I can see my graph here.
Ok, that was all for this very first lesson. You learnt how to make the simplest audio
graph possible, and how to visualize the graph. In the next lesson, we will add in
the middle, here, different nodes for processing the sound like having control over the stereo,
making filters... like an equalizer, and things like that...